in that title too where it says
Millennial they're financially dependent
on their parents what's up with those
parents what kind of parent I know yours
wouldn't I know yours wouldn't I know
yours didn't what type of parent is is
sitting there paying for their kid at 36
years old being dependent on this kid
and they're probably struggling
themselves that parent need go bro at 18
my mom and dad were like all guys all
three of us get byy military byy all
three cuz you all graduated one year at
a time 36 years old you're chilling over
there and your mommy and daddy are
paying your bills it it falls on you
ultimately but what kind of parent lets
their kid just keep giving them money
till 36 and then they're like okay now
you have to go and and face the real
world they're not going to be ready for
it bro the parent has some type of role
in this as well yeah they do it's called
entitlement the parents set them up in
entitlement I don't need to go any
deeper into this topic I love Pat's
summation intentional accidental by
force we see ex I see examples of it in
my family my extended family and it
that's what that's what it it is they